i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo nuovo
video di se non mi dico dove si chiama
gioco siamo su tutti i device in
partenza il nuovo sito ragazzi ormai sto
andando avanti con livelli non ci sto
giocando tantissimo ultimamente raga
perché sto lavorando tanto e io ho un
lavoro sia mai che si passa parola così
su youtube
però non ci sto giocando troppissimo se
non in live perché non c'è stato un
sacco di lo vediamo un gassman comunque
spero di riuscire a fare una bella
partita perché con due mi sto allenando
sempre comunque italia spero di riuscire
a vincere un paio anche oggi si certo
nelle ultime notizie contenute in 292 in
due video quindi almeno almeno una anche
oggi sarebbe non sarebbe male sono primo
perfetto balasko toglietevi raga io non
ho io io posso fare lo posso fare una
precisazione
come mai come mai il cibo e caso che né
lei né l'ultima piattaforma quando ci
sono quelle che robe a rosa io credo
semplice non è cliccato sempre mi
superano come se la gente non soffrisse
della rotazione o team del tag madonna
ragazzi ma king e il tag non si non la
facevo da ma saranno vent'anni non
faccio stavano a prove pronto per sente
di fu madre si posa laita scherzavo
ragazzi no no no no no no vengo a
citofonare il citofono ma io te lo sfido
e citofono dello sviluppo arco dei vari
finite qua poi con le code maledetti
minaccia voi è vero che la mia strada ne
ha otto dicono sempre 65 niente aveva
perso pero l'unico non averla cosa
praticamente grazie
e sapete che è molto bisfrattato il
centro della mappa perché alle cose però
effettivamente 2 op reso un abbonato e
mi sono cagato ho fatto anche la rima
sono un fenomeno che io che ok ok che
perfetto perfetto effetto gli ex 8
fronte alla finanza privati comunque 8
perfetto è un sacco che non gioca questa
mappa comunque ragazzi grazie lavorato
hanno visto il nome principale ed ex
siamo di nuovo in ci credo che culo
posso farvi vedere la tattica adesso che
l'anno scorso vide non sono uscito quali
posso fare della tattica perché siamo in
pochi e vi faccio vedere che cos'è
secondo me la tattica giusta di
extrapola allora a prendere le uova come
addio devi togliere prenderle nuova
lanciarle il a tornare indietro
riprenderle uova e rilanciarle di là del
sopra sensato il ponte per uffici
conviene ragazzi aspettare poco che il
ponte di scena come fa lui questo è
molto bravo sul momento perché fate
prima ad aspettare che il ponte discenda
che a fare il genoa è molto più utile
aspettare che scenderemo il ponte
fidatevi ok io chiamo che questo questa
pratica qua ragazzini presenti di
buttare le uova davanti alla nostra base
poi c'è sicuramente qualcuno che li le
prende le butta dentro o da bravi se
siete voi che vedete le prove davanti
alla base è buttata dentro alle volte le
uova sono abbastanza veloci cadono da
sole perché riescono a rotolare fino in
centro quindi molto utile stabile però
non sono sicuro di sta roba quindi
l'ultima cosa che ho detto panetta con
le pinze va bene come sempre ragazzi una
volta individuata la squadra debole in
questo caso la nostra si va a sabotare
la squadra per tentare di micha
rientrato passa passano in due
l'importante è che si indeboliscano le
ali agli altri la tattica per indebolire
raga sempre questa andare di sopra e
lanciare luogo fuori molto utile sta
cosa quindi come se fosse nell nba
ei fari tiri da tre punti mi sa che
hanno perso inglobava benissimo perché
almeno i brevi rossi ha tenuto occupati
del suo valore
mamma mia che partita rischiosa però
george obama veniva vere avere buono
buono ragga jam sola non va bene è la
mia preferita di questa season perché è
cambiata è più bella secondo me rispetto
a prima è il salone rapella ed è
diventata uno schifo perché la gente ha
iniziato a correre quindi tutti si
suicidano è vice cap culo jean show down
è l'unica che è diventata abbastanza
meritocratica rispetto della più
meritocratica in realtà adesso 9
eliminati in questa guerra buona giaccio
daune perché giusto numero di persone
giusta determinazione perché la prima
partita di oggi in genere ragazzi le
prime partite le vinco sempre ha voglia
di fare ho detto sta cagata un minimo
adesso mi tirano una scoppola che il
caso e gli spena mon gas e stava
succedendo
non so come faccia essere vivo non so se
mi conviene per aspettate mamma mia se
mi conveniva mamma mi essere un passato
di paro lavoro morto porco demonio porco
no no no no no assoluto non è vero
orco dimonio chi l'ha inventato che
maledetto il carnevale e non solo quello
di viareggio ma tutti proprio meno male
che aveva appena dentro la prima vinco
sempre perfetto me lo stai zitto zitto
dai dai una nuovola nuovo la nuova night
fever night fever la febbre del
cavaliere del sabato sera frecce ma
sapete che io pensavo l'avessero tolta
perché non l'avevo più vista qualora
siano ragazzi non avevo più visto freak
sud invece non l'hanno tolta va bene
fresco ma thomas kean del drago che
bella
no no anzi o semi gravi però io devo
portare veramente
ti porto
qualcuno in casa che ti smonta la
playstation stacco tutte le viti della
playstation che monto unisport tu che
giochi solo a polgai se non si può
giocare perché su disco
questa cosa più brutta che ti faccio non
mi chiamare perché ti giuro lo faccio
ti mando il tecnico perfetto momento
tutto è perfetto rare abbiamo pure
assoluti altre non sia più che decente
vabbè che con 17 né men in teoricamente
non esce l'ultimo ai ragazzi forse sì
forse un ex con in 17 in realtà è una
delle delle mappe che di più gradisco
della rue standiana season però
effettivamente tifa sclerare male con un
omaggio di bene speriamo favelas e uno
no no hai capito male problema è capito
maestro hai capito malissimo è capito
malissimo se io se per caso la nomi
ancora non mi è ancora successo
come dire che culo molto amico
soprattutto no se per caso dovesse
succedere che ios posto una roba per
salire per entrare in un cerchio e la
usa qualcun altro per entrarci io andrò
bari in casa sua e gli small tall xbox
che vi ho montato prima e ci crea un
game boy advance lo giuro
manca in tutto questo un cerchio manca
un account ne manca uno che un ottima
posizione pro sono i vasti in dieci
no scusate se non si 7
esce subito stava per molto più facile
hexagon mamma mia ex ragazzi è l'unica
che speriamo di vincerla perché già la
prima l'abbiamo persa oggi a 2 finale
non solo valeva almeno una vittoria che
in questo anche se non lo giocate male
tra nel jobs od anche porco demonio
beccato con una coincidenza sbagliata
non correte donna guarda non devi
correre
non so se ho reso l'idea pratiche
cadente perché volete cosa consiste lo
saprete saltate ragazzi perché la gente
ha iniziato a correre
non è con prima non correvano tutto per
me tutto per prese buona ma non è vero
ma non con non corre non corre non
correre correre correre via perché col
nuovo perché col nuovo i ragazzi non
correva la gente ogni tanto prima perché
con lo slip correte perché perché la
gente corre comotto non sbaglia valutari
sono un babbo di minchiate
pure io mi ci metta la gente con non
correre il giro cose non correre più
bravo tu così saltiamo saltiamo no no no
perché la gente corre e perché ove
ragazzi ma probabilmente visto il figlio
di volker beck i nomi ad hoc onetech
secondo vinto tante troppe
no non ho iniziato rifiuto perché io
vincerei se non perché la gente giocava
tutti giocavano bene nessuno corre ma
perché si è messa a correre la gente con
la nuova silvio ma cosa che ha fatto
venire il cervello la nuova season cosa
cosa perché corrente non correte correte
perdete anche voi siete pazzi pazzi sono
falsi no no no guarda quello che corre
qua qua con giornata ammazzo ti ammazzo
cosa cosi
io no io no io non posso dire non posso
giocare non ci posso giocare costate non
ci posso giocare non correre no ragazzi
nuovi pre allora finisce qui il video
ma perché nella nuova season la gente
corre ma quello che mi è corso in faccia
fine cosa che ci ha guadagnato ha perso
ha perso anche lui non correre ragazzi
io concludo poi vino basta sono stanco
morto sono sudato marcio canale sia vero
peccato perché non arrivata neanche una
vittoria oggi però sono gli ottimi
finale due volte sono viste le mappe
nuove quindi ok di metterli lasciato il
commento è che al prossimo video bergamo
[Musica]